it's either cut wood or go get a job  make money and buy oil I'd much rather  go cut wood  yeah let's truth leaning definitely the  wrong way but at least I don't have to  worry about dropping it on the dogs  [Music]  when trees are leaning they can only go  one direction so you're at the mercy of  the lien of the tree  [Music]  [Music]  you just don't wanna come down do you  trees hang up sometimes multiple times  and it makes for a lot more work  I dropped I think four trees just to try  and get it to where I could cut it up  for firewood  I'll get back in there and stumble  around and try and get the rest of the  wood another day one hundred fifty  hundred pounds hundred fifty pounds it's  not too bad has to be enough wood for  probably five days  [Music]